Xin chào bạn ở
anh alo
Hôm nay mình sẽ từ được chữa đồ ăn nhé
ở những
nhóm nào
a kinh view code khi bình luận nhé à
làm mình thấy à vẫn là vẫn Ôi có vào
nhóm thì giờ
áo kiểu hơi bị mất tích một tí Ừ nhưng
mà Thì mình
cá nhân mình nghĩ hình như mình bảo thì
anh 20 tháng 10 mà nóng lạnh đôi khi
chúng ta có
Ừ vậy thì này
ừ ừ
Ừ hôm qua hôm qua mình là
cho con ít cà phê với bạn thì bạn ấy
cũng lại nói lại với mình về cái bài
toán là đôi khi ở miễn phí một cái gì đó
thì nhiều người sẽ không trân trọng nó
nên là đôi khi có những khóa học nó sẽ
phải kiểu dạng nhà nó sẽ phải có thêm
một cái kiểu là
gọi lắm một chút tiền kiểu cảnh như thế
cốt để cho người khác khi mà học nghe sẽ
trở khi bỏ ra họ sẽ bị áp lực đồng tiền
nữa để mà để mở trân trọng khóa học hơn
em thậm chí có nhiều khóa học thì nó
nhiều na na tương tự thế nhưng mỗi tội
là kiểu
đóng Đóng xong rồi thì đến cuối phá thì
có thể trả lại nếu mà cắm kết là học học
kết thúc khóa kiểu Cái Thế mày ông biết
mấy khóa cái đấy ạ thì à
sau
khi mình thì cũng biết hiểu về mấy cái
đấy nhưng mình sẽ có góc nhìn khác một
tí đó là sao đó là cái cái thực sự thực
sự Mà mà cái người
Ừ cái đối tượng mà tôi hướng đến đấy
ừ ừ
chính xác không phải là là người chưa
biết gì ít nhất ở trong tài khóa này
không phải là người chưa biết gì mà
chính xác lại là phù hợp cho
À à người chưa Cái gì có thể đúng nhưng
ý tôi là phải dùng từ như thế nào nhỉ
Không phải là cho mấy cái bạn mà mà kiểu
dạng mà mới tinh hoàn toàn mà theo kiểu
là
mình mấy tuổi 18 tuổi hay là sinh viên
năm nhất năm hai mà về hướng của tôi lại
làm phù hợp về cái việc là những sinh
viên đã ra trường hoặc là đang học nhưng
mà có vấn đề ở trên trường tại sao tôi ở
hướng đến đối tượng lạ thế bởi vì a
giống như khá nhiều người inbox của tôi
họ bình luận thì tớ gà Họ học ở trên
trường họ cảm thấy làn da bởi vì cách
chiến trường dạy có thể khó hiểu với bạn
đấy hoặc không truyền cảm hứng cho bạn
đấy hoặc là bạn đấy ra trường rồi như
bạn không thấy phù hợp với cái nhàng mà
bạn này đã chọn và bạn ấy muốn chọn con
đường khác thì cái khóa học của tôi thì
rất là phù hợp với mấy bạn đấy bởi vì
sao Bởi vì ý của tôi không tạo thêm với
áp lực gì nữa cho bạn này nữa tính nhất
là về mặt vật chất Lấy kiểu thế nó sẽ
cho các bạn ấy đúng nghĩa là thêm một cơ
hội nữa để mà một cơ hội một mạch dụng
từng mục một cơ hội để mở ra một con
đường ra con đường này về cơ bản thì mấy
ông thấy thì tôi vẫn cầm tay chỉ rồi khá
nhiều thì nó vẫn tương đối bằng phẳng và
với với những bạn kiểu Giả sử là mới mới
đi học đại học trở lại 25 mét 52 học gì
thì cái này nó lại khiến nó các bạn đấy
cảm thấy là dễ quá A và tinh thần tự
giác của mấy bạn ấy kém gọi là bạn đấy
chưa chưa trải đổi thì bạn ấy sẽ thấy à
có đường này phòng phiếu quá khứ no cái
tinh thần tự giác bạn ấy kém và bạn lại
không trân trọng khóa học để ơi tôi biết
nhưng mà tôi bảo rồi tôi không hướng đến
những các bạn như thế mà chính xác tôi
hướng đến những cái bạn mà tinh thần tự
giác mặc định là cao bạn đấy đã từng
trải qua những cái khó khăn Sẵn rồi nên
là khi mà gặp gặp một cái có đường rẽ
như thế Dậy đi như thế thì bạn đấy cảm
thấy à Nó như một cái lối đi gì đó để mà
một cái mở con đường mới cho bạn đấy
Kiểu gì hết giả hết đấy Mục tiêu của tôi
hôm đấy Chính xác là như thế nghĩa là
ở nhà ông học của chén trường hoa mấy
ông Thực ra thấy ổn rồi trở ra học của
tôi nó cũng chẳng có thêm được mấy cái
gì mấy cũng nói thêm thỉnh thoảng thêm
một vài mẹo Còn nếu mà giờ sử mà các bạn
đã học trên trường chả hiểu cái gì cả
đấy
thiết kế khóa không phải cái cái chung
ấy chính xác là khỏa toàn bộ khóa học
của anh ý Anh mục tiêu nó như thế đấy
nghĩa làm chỉ là phù hợp cho người tuổi
ở vẫn chưa biết gì hoặc cả biết rồi
nhưng mà cảm thấy là trên trường dạy 01
khó hiểu gì gì đó thì thì khi mà học của
anh thì sẽ cảm thấy nó một sự khác biệt
so với kiểu học đại học chính quy ít
nhất như thế
cho nên Đây là họ có thể sẽ trân trọng
hơn chứ anh không Chúng mình không hướng
đến là kiểu dạng là là dành cho các bạn
kiểu dạng là mình mình không ép các bạn
là phải tập đúng ạ không ép các bạn một
cái gì cả Không thu phí mới cái gì cả
các thứ mọi thứ để trên tinh thần tự
nguyện thì thì những các bạn sẽ phải tự
tự giác và chủ yếu và các bạn nếu mà
từng trải rồi từng nhảy là theo cậu đã
biết được à Ở ngoài kia nó để đổ mù học
như thế này chẳng ạ Cũng không hẳn là
như này tôi khẳng định có nhiều hoa có
tạo mỡ hơi nó cũng có cái giá cắt cổ
cũng có lừa dùng để lừa cũng có đấy à
anh hoặc là kiểu các bạn chiến giản là
đang bế tắc không biết theo ngành gì thì
đây là một cái cơ hội Các bạn nhìn thấy
à Mình thấy cái này miễn phí và cũng tận
tâm nhiệt tình mình sẽ thử học xem sao
mình không mất gì cả mất một tí thời
gian để mà học thôi Nếu mà không ổn thì
thôi Không và đấy và quan trọng nữa đó
là vì nó không có tính chất thương mại
gì cả những thành ra là các bạn vừa bị
không bị thêm một cái áp lực về mặt tiền
bạc thứ hai đó là tôi cũng sẽ giờ thoải
mái khi mà dậy Cho tôi hỏi mã ở đây
không phải là là tôi sẽ không nghiêm túc
với nó là thoải mái ở đây ăn chị ạ Các
bạn sẽ từ ra cũng chẳng khuyên ý kiến
thì là nếu bạn có vấn đề gì đó nhưng mà
tôi vẫn sẽ chịu trách nhiệm nếu mà nếu
mà dậy sai Giả sử phát ngôn có gì sai gì
đó Đương nhiên mình vẫn sẽ chịu trách
nhiệm đối ngoại
Em có phải người ta cho em mình vừa mình
bạn miễn phí mày đừng có đòi hỏi tôi
không nói như thế Bây giờ cả đấy
anh
nha Đấy tìm mấy ông tôi muốn tâm sự lại
một lần nữa về cái việc là không có
người cũng vẫn khuyên tôi là kiểu chỉ
cần à Bảo đóng một tí thôi Thì ra nó
cũng chẳng đáng là bao có là đẹp mà rồi
Đúng kiểu một cốc trà sữa cũng chẳng hạn
1 tháng điều gì và vẫn cốt để cho mấy
ông ấy khi mà đóng tiền rồi ôm bởi vì
sao một mình nhiều người rất quan trọng
vì tiền bạc cái này ra khi mà họ bỏ tiền
bạc vào cho nó thì họ quan trọng luôn cả
cái kia đấy tâm lý đấy mấy ông nên sửa
dần thì trông sẽ ổn hơn có những thứ
đúng là miễn phí nó tại thật nhưng có
những thứ gì nó miễn phí thì không không
phải là nó à mà nó tẩy đúng không ạ vơ
tôi có vừa đọc một cái à
Tôi vừa đọc xong cái Vệ phần mềm VLC
VLC free I
ạ
bây giờ C để mở xem ấy và nó đã từ chối
từ chối
quảng cáo
cho đến bây giờ là phải chục triệu đâu
rồi để mà được miễn phí và nó sẽ mãi
miễn phí kiểu như thế nó không thu đồng
quảng cáo nó cả anh rất là hay nghĩa có
những cái miễn phí không không nhất
thiết là sẽ sẽ kiểu tệ hay cái gì đó
đóng ngoặc
và đương nhiên là nó sẽ nó sẽ kiểu đem
lại có lợi cho đôi bên không ạ Ừ tôi vẫn
nghĩ thế bởi vì bây giờ nếu tôi nổi lên
thì kiểu gì cũng sẽ có lợi cho bản thân
thôi đầu tiên đã
ở đây à Tôi không thu phí của mấy ông
bằng tiền thôi Nhưng tôi sẽ có cách khác
không ạ Mà không phải là bây giờ chạy
quảng cáo nhé à
Ừ ok Bây giờ mình xin phép mà
cho xem
U23 tháng 7
13 tháng 7 ông này lâu lắm không cập
nhật cốt này
tôi kể này tiếp
nhé
em cảm nhận những cái gì nhỉ
mới xem xong lập trình web với một à
vợ
chồng vào đây ông nội
ông sẽ chẳng hiểu cái gì đó
bà mày
vệ thủ nha Ừ Ừ
cứ cho bảo vệ thử đi mình mình mình nghĩ
là cứ bảo vệ thù để mà để mà kiểu xem
tiến độ từng nhóm ta như thế nào Có vài
nhóm thì cũng tương đối đấy có phải nhóm
tương đối rồi
ông sẽ càng biết số tín nhiệm các thử
chứ đúng không
ý nghĩa không sao cả
điểm mà bấm mà vậy nó sẽ cho mở nhanh
xem được qua tiện hơn
các kiểu nhà nó sẽ mời nhanh là được đi
ổ cắm ba
D3 có nhiều cái vẫn chưa làm đến Amino
ở bên người dùng chứ cái nó Min thì có
vẻ làm tao xem
A và
ừ ừ
giống như tôi thường à Hồi trước ngày
làm đó là nếu không sẽ phải à
Ừ ừ
nên lấy cái mới nhất
lectus mà mới nhất thì nó sẽ ổn hơn ông
ấy vẫn dùng cho thuê bồ
Âm Nhạc
em không khóc không phải
đi mua đồ ngoài để viết thường thức
không nên nhai lắm nhưng phải hoa trước
cái đâu ạ
ờ ờ có được bảo vệ thử không ạ Có mỗi
bác em còn son em Bọn bạn em chưa phát
triển ý ông à sẽ như thế nào
bảo đúng ơi bảo vệ thử nói chung là đại
khái cái buổi bảo vệ thủ lấy để tôi nói
lại nhé
Anh
bảo vệ Thứ bảy mà thứ 7
từ ngày
12 ngày 13 tháng 8 năm 2022 bảo vệ thử
đợt 1 tổ chức
ra tôi không quan tâm giao diện lắm
nhưng mà chắc chắn lắm nếu không phải có
giao diện nghĩa là
có thể là chưa có tablet
Ừ nhưng mà bắt buộc không không phải bảo
vệ là là là kiểu cho xem suốt đâu nhé
bảo vệ bản chất vẫn là phải có giao diện
để mà thao tác với giao diện nha
thì chưa cầm chưa cầm Tablet này cần
kiểu giao diện đẹp có những thứ ở
a tiếp theo là tự nhiên phải có tính
năng chính rồi
em có tính năng chính của đồ án rồi tính
năng chính của đồ án thì nó sẽ là như
thế nào Ví dụ là quản lý
tên phần mềm là cái gì tính năng chính
thì đấy
và phần mềm Đặt lịch tự nhiên phải có
cái tính năng đặt lịch rồi phần mềm quản
lý sinh viên thì là phải có những kiểu
quản lý rồi đấy các thứ hướng để tôi
đánh giá xem là cái tính năng chính của
ông đã xong chưa còn tính năng phụ thôi
không quan tâm bảo vệ hãy nhớ đón Hay là
thêm mấy ông chỉ có những cái gì đó thực
sự là kiểu nó hay ho nó khác với chỉ đơn
giản thêm sửa xóa bình thường thì ông bị
khoe chứ bây giờ có rất nhiều bảng ông
cũng ngồi khoe thêm sửa xóa thì chắc là
hết ngày không ạ Đấy thì đón hay là sẽ
hiểu gần như là Anh Không Cần
em chưa cần
là ai và
phải liệu đó lấy nghĩa là mấy ông sẽ chỉ
cần có thể trực tiếp ngồi nói luôn rồi
nó luôn kiểu dạng là người thằng vào
tính năng chính sau để mô các thứ để tôi
xem qua luôn xem là kiểu của mấy ông cần
phải sửa gì Không mục tiêu của cái đồ án
sẽ thế tiêu này
kiểm tra xem tính năng
Ừ quan trọng
ổn chưa Tức là sao Tức à là
đúng nghiệp vụ không đúng nghĩa vụ này
và dễ hiểu dễ rung
của cái bảo vệ thử của cái thứ bảy này
chứ không phải là kiểu để để kiểu dạng
là
để khoe là do diện hay là cậu như nào
đấy có trà
à à
em ăn gì để đi phỏng vấn ạ
rồi nhưng mà bạn chắc là bạn à lên trên
mạng có Trao tài liệu tra Google cũng ra
nhiều đấy phỏng vấn công nghệ thông tin
ấy
nói chung và mấy ông hiểu được ý tưởng
của Thứ Bảy là ngày rồi đúng không tại
thì cứ chuẩn bị nha
kia run hộ mình nhé á
Bộ Công an Việt Nam show đê
Vì sao rồi mình có đeo tay nữ
bộ phim student update controller Ừ vợ
đi Tam anken.cho tơi chưa có cái gì cả
ừ ừ
bộ nhớ ngoài có thấy ít vậy chẳng có cô
thì mấy đây
gì cả Không biết chấm gì luôn
ở cột Hôm trước ok
ha ha anh em
còn được ngay Cường em
platin made là tại sao lại lại kiểu đầu
với một đống pha này mẫu ngoài có mít
kiểu trông buồn cười nữa kiểu ghi
sơ sài này cái làm việc là chọn file
chọn hết một đống như này vãi chưởng
em về rồi xem nhé
cuối là được Nó không ảnh hưởng gì mấy
nó không tác động là những file khác
Facebook là được lợi nhưng không tốt
động phải không Sao ạ
à à
Ừ ừ
ông mày làm à
à à
anh nghe Chắc vậy
ở đâu sao
ê ê để tôi xem nhé
anh không
nếu mà một cách viết kiểu nhà nha sẽ sửa
lại như này ghét như này
ở shop
colore phải ngay ID là xong à
nhưng sao ta tự thế
bài viết này không hiểu luôn
như này để xuống dưới này
ông bà ngày từ cái đoạn này kiểm tra là
mình thử cái À hồi như đồ ăn một tôi dậy
À thì ra xuất và lưu có thể để để chống
như này rồi like như này Những thứ tha
người ông bản chất là nếu mà quê ngay
vẫn khiến nó chỉ cần mắt nặng đúng không
ạ là tốt nhất là mình không lấy kiểu như
này mình sẽ làm à hiểu
Chỉ khi nào nó có thì mình mới nên à
à mình mình mới lên shop à
nó sẽ kiểu à
ở nhà được
anh không cần bằng đâu cà ri thẳng như
thế này nó với đề và cục máy không cần
bằng đâu đấy
đây như này
Ừ thì có thể dùng cái hats kiện được mà
và
anh bằng bóng điểm vào nó khác luôn này
xe hơi dị mẹ cốt cho này chồng hơi dị
như tôi từng nói mày không nên khai báo
hết toàn bộ vì quét ở trên hay bây giờ
như thế này
a tiếp theo totopaz
có gì
không muốn hiểu loại này
Ừ ok
- meet with osad remix
A Z
ừ ừ
Ô thế không khác gì dùng Pantene AK cả
Tại sao lại không chụp cái nếp nhỉ
xe hơi lạ
Ừ vậy cũng được
ê kê Movado
nhiều rồi để tôi
đi tạm bỏ qua nhóm mày đi chữa từ nhóm
cuối lên trên lên trên như vậy bởi mấy
cái nhóm kia gừng chữa nhiều rồi Cậu lúc
nào nhóm đấy danh sách đầu ấy tôi sẽ
chữa từ nhóm này lên nha
ờ ờ
tủ bếp Vietsub
Em đừng có nên gộp cả hai chục picture
nó sẽ sửa tính năng rồi Nó thêm một tính
năng mới không phải là cập nhật Cái gì
cả và chắc chắn nó sẽ không phải để liên
quan pixbox mấy ông lười có mít quá đẩy
một con nít gộp vậy Không nên như thế
này nhá Đây
đến tận
9 cái file controller vào năm file biết
được Where vậy trưởng
đi làm kiểu này
Anh đi làm rồi chết May mà đầy đủ ẩn của
Ông chưa ông Kiều riêng với quả con nít
mà liên quan đến tận mây cái controller
tôi là một người
à à cốt Hán nhiều Xong rồi à nhưng một
lần một lần kiểu
diploid của tôi lên đã từng có lần là
liên quan đến trận ba mươi mấy file có
nhưng nhưng
ý của tôi tách riêng ra rất nhiều con
nít chứ không phải hộp chung một con mi
kiểu nhé
cho
nên là người ta hoàn toàn thế xem được
có mít của tôi và thích hệ reverse nghĩa
là kiểu dáng Nếu mà sẽ xử cốt của vấn đề
gì đó thì chỉ cần khôi phục lại vuốt lại
cái cũng nít nào đó thôi chứ bây giờ tôi
mà reverse cái này vì vất có mít như này
là có như là bay hết tận chính file
controller
không phải bay thì nó hơi quá Nhưng bay
hết cốt trong thuận 92 con theo lời chết
em ạ Có những cái tính năng là kiểu nói
chung và về cơ bản thì thích thì ông
tách riêng này nhanh nhất Future mày
không bảo vệ sinh riêng này update thì
mày không gộp nhiều file này tay có thể
tha thứ
từng ca Đấy nó phải tách Dương hả mà làm
tôi chưa biết ông làm tính năng gì mà
liên quan tâm 92 cân cho lâu đấy à
Ồ sao Vậy cậu muốn làm xong hết rồi đẩy
một con nít thôi không nên làm thế
xem thử Sorry nhé à
ở
Sorry đâu nhỉ Ở đây
em đi chưa có gì cả Ok ở
này
sai bản chất là thằng này nó có cái à
em mặc định ở shop Dalat rồi mà nhỉ mình
đâu cần phải thêm cái điều kiện này đâu
nhỉ shop Elise mặc định là walloon heo
này rồi mày nghỉ hơi lạ đấy tự nhiên ví
luôn thêm làm gì nữa
Ý em là khóa
về cơ bản này khoản nâng cao nhỉ Anh
cũng Thực ra anh chả nhớ lắm rồi mày cái
vụ này cơ nhưng mà thường là khóa cơ bản
là anh đã dạy cách thiết kế ra đây rồi
là từ từ số Lộc thẻ ra tao bay các thứ
thứ rồi
mẹ ID
Ừ đợi tí đợi tôi một tí
Hà Nội tâm tí than tren này
hơi buồn cười tôi ghét Tại sao lại ghét
nhỉ Hay đi còn nhiều à
Anh chưa hiểu đoạn này lắm
ở bảng cây này có
đi AD chỉ có 10 nhỉ Dạo này bạn này bạn
làm à
khi nhận đề first để lấy thằng đầu tiên
này
ạ Và nếu mà dùng quay đi này file Nhưng
mà nếu mà bạn kết hợp với việc cả bếp
như này tôi sẽ dùng thường mà tôi sẽ làm
nha check này Tôi đặt tên nó check về
phía sau nếu mà trong ngày chỉ có đúng
một thằng thì tôi sẽ đạt tưởng như này à
toàn bộ những cái đầu mày không ạ Toàn
bộ Cái này tôi sẽ
vứt nó vào trong một cái là kiểu ta nha
bằng cả mạng chứ ai chẳng hạn sau đó thì
ừ ừ
Ừ
đợi tí
anh sẽ mở code bằng bên này để cho nó
dùng cây pho mát cho đẹp đi
A
và đặt tên hàm không phải thăm trên đâu
đó tên hàng nó sẽ tên hàm thì mình sẽ
luôn là động từ đằng trước
khi chọn đua lao động từ đằng trước
ờ ờ
Anh thường là như thế Bây giờ trên than
này có thử thứ con con nếu mà ông muốn
làm cái kiểu là để lấy nó ra thì sẽ là
Index này họ pre Sting là đó còn nếu mà
ông để cậu như này chứ không phải thêm
chữ s để hiểu nó xuống nhiều
xe đẩy dọn hàng đây xuống nhiều mà đúng
không ạ
anh ạ
object nha file để
truyền toàn bộ data vào trong như thế
này đó
tôi muốn làm ở chỗ ngắn hơn thì nó sẽ
chở ngay thôi à à à
a request
access này
em
lấy mỗi ID lọc mỗi ID is a song
à Anh ơi nữa song với điều kiện là ông
của cái tên cột xong rồi xếp này xong
khi họ
anh không bỏ được cái update này rồi
gì sau đó trả về thì mình sẽ chỉ cần trả
về đúng mỗi thằng áo rách kia là xong
Ê
pete ơn muốn khách hàng nhé này
anh nghe được
Perman đúng không
với ông kể hàm kiểu viết kiểu ngày rồi
nhưng tôi khuyên mày ông mà không nên
viết kiểu ngay về sau làm ấy muốn sửa
tên cột hay gì đó thì ngồi không biết
anh không biết rồi cái đoạn này ở đâu
chết gà không không nên làm Tắt cả nhà
mình vẫn nên ghi rõ tên cột các thứ ra
thì nó hợp lý hơn
Ê
bà
bà Kiểu mình copy nó dễ hơn nữa
khi nghe tôi khuyên mày ông mà không lên
như này mà tôi tách selec ra nó không
nên gộp ở nhà luôn đấy Ờ và
có một vài trường hợp với tôi sẽ dùng
que kiểu như này có một cái trường hợp
đấy cho AB từ 0 - 1 chia sẻ mấy ông ấy
chưa trả xong rồi ông lại ngồi ngồi Cậu
bắt chước kiểu nhà chết
ở mặt trước cả ngày mà không hay đâu nha
cốt kiểu ngay thì về sau mà đổi tên cột
cái này nó lỗi Đông ạ Nó không phải một
cái hai đâu
Tôi còn nhớ không lầm mà thực ra cái
quýt này mình nên tách riêng từng cái
từng cái cơ Ừ nếu mà để gộp chung ngày
tôi nhớ là một thằng không có mấy thằng
kia bị vấn đề gì đó thì phải
Ừ nhớ mà mãi chưa
chả để hôm sau tôi mới xem cái cụ thể ở
ngoài virus luôn ở trong này
À hôm nay ra đến luôn trong này như này
ừ ừ
bài hát
quá
ở đây này ta này nó sửa người ta này có
thể tách ra chỗ khác đúng chứ
OK này
rồi quét rồi không cần nói được tiền lại
như này
Ừ ok nè đô
đó chính xác là ông ở dùng 3 đến ông
dùng cả ngày rồi thì ông ở
cho xem
nằm chính xác rồi đây lấy từ từ cái ba
đến mà còn nữa ông gọi Ông đã gọi dùng
vai date Đợt này rồi xong lại gọi đến
cậu biến kiểu ngày nữa thì nó bị sai bản
chất
ở cầu Dạ ông đã lấy những cái đã được đã
được lọc rồi không ạ Xong rồi ông này
lại kiểu lấy cái bình thường nhưng cả
những cái này ở chợ lọc thì sao không ạ
kiểu máy tắt cả là Em viết tắt kiểu này
thì
Ừ mình hạn chế với tắt được thì tốt
35 Quyết là điều mà sàn thêm sunship của
razzil của anh có quần có sự thử thôi
em phải dùng em phải
dùng phím tắt của nó chứ
có phím tắt của nó thì thì em mới cậu
lại được nghỉ
a Pocket lại
ờ ờ huyện tôi chưa cả các kỹ đấy phải
nói chung là em phải cái cái phim bắt
của nó xong thì mới được chứ không phải
là kiểu Hiền nhiên nào đó cài xong nó sẽ
được
I finish quattro attendant à
Ừ cũng được đặt tên kiểu nhà nghe mà vẫn
hợp nhiều file quá cùng một lúc này ra
cho tôi không thích
phim Harry Potter Harry Potter hết
sạn đáng cân Zalo
nên để nó là public nữa mình không dùng
à Dạ live nữa mình mình chỉ dùng ở đây
thích kia ông để nó ngay ở chỗ này được
không cần này có ăn đi nằm ở đây
Argentina consoled Chị Mỗi này nữa
ừ ừ
can dien tu dien
à à thêm vì quẹt
đấy Cả
chị đã có gì nhỉ à
Ừ ừ
a few of music in its cho
I could
được mấy cái tính năng nhỏ nhỏ giống như
thông báo này cái gì đó các bạn muốn
hoàn thiện cái sản phẩm của mình đúng
không sao nhưng mà tính năng chính phải
có trước đã rồi mày cái kia mới làm dần
Các bạn cứ kiểu à bây giờ đấy Bây giờ
cậu Hai ngày nữa bảo vệ rồi đúng không
Nhưng mà tính năng chỉnh các bạn luôn
chứ có thế nên là
thế làm sao mà kịp được Bây giờ đầu
tháng bé gần như giữa tháng 8 rồi mà một
tháng nữa mới ông bảo vệ kiểu như thế và
với cái tiếng nộc kiểu Hiện tại thì sẽ
không thể kịp được nhớ là sự là kiểu
1 tháng đối với tôi thử làm đồ về tôi
thẳng
hi hoa cặp đôi đối với tôi bây giờ không
nói nhưng đối với tôi Cậu của cái hồi mà
tôi làm đồ ăn hay thì một tháng vẫn đủ
để tôi ngồi làn lúc mà mới chỉ có đang
tính năng cơ bản làm xong rồi cả tính
năng nâng cao về bản chất tính năng cao
thì cùng nó mà mất hai tuần thứ mấy nếu
mà ông cậu đấy Ông còn gặp bức Còn nếu
mong làm trôi chảy thì nó nhanh nữa đúng
không ạ nhưng mà
anh với tiến độ hiện tại của nhiều nhóm
thì bây giờ đang bị hiểu đấy giống như
một lần Con Mít tôi thấy nó chả có cái
gì cả mà đã thấy một tuần chỉ có miếng
một lần thì tôi không biết ở chế độ của
mấy ông sẽ như thế nào không ạ Mấy ông
tập trung vào giao diện này hoặc là mấy
cái kiểu nó hơi bị gặp mặt một tí nó
không Vẫn Tôi thấy ít nhóm bây giờ vẫn
chưa có cái tính năng chính
em mới chỉ có thêm sửa xóa các thứ thứ
Ừ thế này thì bao giờ bảo vệ được
này xong rồi thông báo rồi Vâng Mà cái
phân xử lý chưa có gọi nhìn truyền sợ
thật rồi
em chuyển ghét ghét ghét hết rồi
không phân chàng luôn chưa hết sao
ưu điểm danh Index điểm danh lấy hết ra
ok ở lấy hết ra trong Shake
Ừ thế này nhiều cái đoạn nên cách tại vì
thế tôi này hết ra rồi
à à
ừ rồi rồi lấy ra
nhà thuốc cái máy rồi đấy
Lại thế nữa là Nếu mà không thuộc giấc
để lấy ra thì nó sẽ dài này dáng sợ thật
đ
trước tôi tưởng ngàn thì quen rồi Ok Thế
bạn ấy có vẻ song với điểm danh nhưng mà
nhưng mà
ờ ờ
tra chặt chẽ hơn đó là đây điểm danh ở
bên A
cô giáo viên à
à à Giáo hội điểm danh có giáo viên à Ok
nó dấu vụ điểm nhanh và viên cũng sao
còn nếu mà giáo viên điểm cho anh thì
đương nhiên là sẽ phải ạ kiểm tra Quyền
của giáo viên nữa Ngoan không phải dễ gì
tự nhiên giáo viên giáo viên được phép
điểm danh hiệu như ai những phải kiểm
tra có thể thứ nữa
ca nhạc nó hiểu cho anh
thế này cốt giống cốt Tôi từng làm nữa
mà không có gì cả
các kiểu Dáng gọn nó còn chả liên quan
mình đến post
ở đây
I năm học
Ừ cũng được
ở ngoài giờ tôi khi tôi từng làm cái vụ
ngay bạn chia anh Mạnh nhiều chiều nha
kiểu là Rooney Yoyo rồi không phải sơn
nữa thì làm cái này thì cao chỉ cần một
đến hai tháng là xong rồi
Ừ đấy là xong cơ bản toàn bộ tính năng
có nếu mà một phát triển cậu tỉnh nâng
cao hơn chuyên nghiệp hơn và giao giao
diện thân thiện hơn giao diện đây không
phải nói về kiểu ôm template về mà thực
ra thực sự rất để ý những cái chi tiết
nhỏ dụ trải nghiệm người dùng tốt hơn
các từ đã để những cái tính năng kiểu nó
nó ổn hơn đấy
Ừ thì sẽ mất thêm thời gian thôi đấy tùy
sự cầu toàn của mỗi người I
làm cả avi Suite care luôn ạ
một tuần có nhiều thời gian mới trả lời
tại nhà rồi Mày làm cái Soccer làm gì
sót cơ này có để mà cậu biến tài liệu
của ông Thành kiểu tài liệu III thì đọc
thì nó biến anh tài liệu dog này
hiểu qua được trang của ông có những
người kia gì
mấy ông nhỉ
Thì đại khái như thế nghĩa là chúng ta
không cần lắm
Chị ngồi mấy ông cứ làm cái cái gì
khi
ngồi lâu không ngồi kiểm tra giữ nhóm từ
cuối đổi lên mấy ông có biết nếu làm gì
không ạ rửa
làm cái cái thằng cần
gọn nhưng mà cập nhật rất nhiều hư kê
chú ý 5 container không ạ
chưa không có biết nhận xét gì mà ông đã
chịu chịu lại chịu mấy ông anh
nhờ từng chữa nhá máy rồi thì phải à
a friend
I thought of class này nó không có tác
dụng gì cả nhưng mà không đi được gọi
này
không ghi cho nhà luôn
chúng ta chung cái gì
vì thế mà vẫn tạo nữa này đầu tiên tôi
thấy đấy
à à
ak3 City ở đây ạ Ừ hình như là nhóm đoạn
này như tôi bảo bỏ đi rồi mày nhắn không
nhỉ
Âm Nhạc
bộ trưởng
a men ra cái đoạn này bị gặp lại cốt này
sắp đến phải to được thỉnh thoảng bị gặp
lại cốt Tôi thường anh kiểu gộp chung nó
lại thì được thì tốt chứ
Ừ kệ nhóm khác
anh chat auto translate
a store
Âm Nhạc
ở Mỹ
cho nhau bởi dấu
hồ cá
khi tôi thấy ông ấy tạo ra đột biến này
nhưng mà dùng ở chỗ nào nhỉ
sửa lại nó phá loại này đi đỡ phải nhỉ
ừ ừ
nào là bên thêm luôn à bên này bên thêm
gì cả
Ừ đúng nhỉ à
ba ngày là hơi mua xi ở điển Tôi không
biết được bên trái bên phải là cái bên A
Em hãy Trưởng
ơi xóa Âm Nhạc
ngày 19 tháng 7 ở ngoài thơ ca nhóm này
nó không cập nhật mà nó qua đi ừ
nhắm vào lớp chưa
các bạn des hommes
Ê mày đi from Nhưng mà thêm gì đấy
a good day
Ồ vãi chưởng không ai làm gì ở này cả
anh em hả
Em hỏi cả
em đứng yên à Có thứ đúng không phải
biết thứ ở
ừ ừ
Ừ cái này xử lý anh khuyên là nên vứt
vào trong thằng áo crack mua đồ bản chất
và container không cần được xử lý luận
này hiểu không
mà tại sao lại xử lý Dạo này ở cái phần
phần controller đúng không tạo ra một
cái kiểu ăn rất là trong mua đồ tương tự
thế Thay thế hoa
à chích chờ gọi ứng tích Châu Á gì có of
Zack
a teacher vậy thích cho Trở Về
a level
Ừ anh về cả nhân Anh không thích dùng
cho từng nói Nếu dùng cho đoạn này nếu
mà em thích kiểu chỉ lấy một cột như này
thì em thế Alo ngay thôi
ăn rau xanh
ở controller này
à à
ở đây
em sẽ lại Zalo này Sao lại mỗi cột này
nó sẽ vỡ first mà lấy một cột này thôi
em sẽ chỉ cần à Gọi kiểu ngày cho nó đỡ
trong nó đỡ có kiểu là thích chờ tí chờ
thằng thích trời này lên nhà nó bị sai
đúng không đối tượng mà
i i
anh em làm chuyện ngay thì đúng nghĩa là
đây là nêm của thích trời thật cái kiểu
thế
dùng heo thôi sẽ tách hẳn ra ngay nếu mà
nếu mà thường sẽ kiểm tra thường luôn
kiểm tra điều kiện sai sau đó đi trở về
là đúng nó sẽ ngược lại như này là nếu
mà không có đúng không
Âm Nhạc
cô gái showbiz hay xuống ngay
khi họ nếu mà em Ti không Nếu vậy MT thì
xin lỗi sau đó thì mình xử lý những cái
đúng luôn chả cái đúng ở quấy còn những
cái sai mình bắt hết trường hợp ở trên
thế này trước đã Return sớm vậy à tretin
tức là sẽ trả về sẽ sẽ phản hồi về sớm
Nếu mà có vấn đề gì đó Cái xử lý nó sẽ
lôgic là sẽ như này nó hợp lý hơn
hay câu nhé
Anh đang cảnh báo này
cái này chị chuyển 100 số thôi
thế này đấy Mấy ông không dùng mấy ông
cứ ngồi chê tôn này mà thông báo này
biến này không được dùng này phải không
thông báo là kiểu nên Tách cái cái ít
Air chẳng hạn n hư đấy không dùng mày
không thấy cho nó không gợi ý cả
này mặc định là đương nhiên là
phải coi đi này được chứ nhỉ Nó sẽ
update thôi mày nữa cho thêm rồi nghỉ
chưa hiểu đó này lắm sao chơi này
anh lại thích chơi
nếu mà
chị xem music đoạn Hãy giới thiệu lắm
đây
cô giáo viên có thiếu thứ Nếu mà
anh cấm chống đẩy ra để xóa
phải xóa nhỉ chưa hiểu rõ lắm
cái đoạn này mới áp đấy nó quyết này
à à
classid sẽ cùng bọn lớp mà không ngâm
mình sẽ làm thay thế thôi
cập nhật là
em đổi giáo viên cũng đây mình update
update mà dựa theo cả lớp Hiện tại thì
có phải là đương nhiên là đã sẽ là thay
thay giáo viên mới đúng không
về chưa
thơ Nguyễn phức tạp thế
Ừ ừ cũng được lại cũng được em Đại khái
nói như này thôi Chắc ai đi ông truyền
lên còn thẳng dùng này
buồn cười không
ý niệm này
ê sexy
Ừ ông truyền nêm lên ông cốt để thông
báo xúc xích nem về
không biết không ai làm thế này nhé
Cái này còn em thì bọn em tự in ra lấy
cái nêm thụ phấn ăn thôi không vậy anh
em ta em mất công chờ này bác Hai em có
để bác em trả về đúng đấy Đúng cái phần
em chưa lên để trả tác dụng gì cả
nice cote không có tôi không quan tâm mà
chỉ thấy em cứ mãi ông có dùng ghi sổ
code cho người mấy ông ngồi cốt có vấn
đề khi tôi thương tôi Cứ đè viscose ra
mà chụp thế thôi
nhỉ Ai đi này không nhìn thấy 55 55 cảnh
báo xong rồi 46 cái cũng là cảnh báo tôi
say xong rồi thay bô 7 cái video code
của mấy ông bơ đỏ lòm khi mở mở cốt này
ông Lê Như Tôi không lấy cảm thấy sai
vãi ha Nó không xử lý cái đấy nhưng mà
I
speak nhìn trâu Online
nếu mà ông được sửa ông bắt theo cậu
Ừ ông thưa Long hay ít màu tối ưu được
càng tốt này
nhưng Mở cốt của tôi lên không Không có
một đống cảnh báo đỏ lòm nghe đâu Chúng
ta là kiểu cốt của mấy ông Vấn đề đúng
không
anh ạ
à À quên cũng chẳng biết được nhóm này
nhóm này anh yêu mới chỉ có cập nhật vài
cái đấy rồi vậy chứ có cái gì cả đúng
không À đây có cả
tất cả điểm danh rồi bây giờ xem thử
điểm danh
Có công mài mòn bắt lỗi thì có lỗi nhiều
lắm
thông cảm nhiều cái nó liên quan không
đọc được đâu Bây giờ mày ông lên báo cột
hay các thứ không tồn tại Ok Không sao
nhưng còn những cái khác Như kiểu cái
này
gì
khác không Cái này liên quan đến việc nó
đang đọc trong các ô che cái đúng cái
này khai báo được nhiều này cái này khai
báo không dùng này
không mua dùng này
Em nói sao
A Gọi cái này qua thứ là tôi dậy mấy ông
cái này rồi kể về một cái vụ hiểu gọi
qua này làm sao
anh em nha
anh Thái for Ừ thầy cô ấy đúng là nó ngu
si thật ok ừ cái file này
không bị lỗi
ở nhà đấy à để nói cảnh báo thôi Nhưng
tôi sẽ vì pho mát lại này em trả lời
Format là bao giờ có thể tôi format theo
cách của tôi khác mấy ông
ờ ờ
Anh Sơn cá nhân tôi tôi không Tôi bảo
tôi không biết dùng with như này mà tôi
sẽ
chế độ dữ liệu thành chỗ khác như ngoại
quýt kiểu ngay
nó mạnh nó hợp lý hơn
Ừ nó dậy sửa hơn à
lịch theo lớp 7 đúng không
ưu điểm danh này
bị khó hiểu cái này sẽ Hàn này sẽ phải
là bản chất nó có Intex ở đây rồi đi
hàng này sẽ file hoặc sâu Nếu mà theo
razzil thì hàng này sẽ sâu Tại sao của
việc sau tất cả Xem chi tiết một cái gì
đó còn Jack thì sẽ liệt kê toàn bộ ra
ngay cả thế
Ừ chứ không cần anh nhắc lại tên của cái
controller này lưu lại ngay ổn này
Anh
tên là store bếp được cái gì bản chất là
cái này nó nó bao gồm cả 2 cả bếp cả cả
clip Mà sao tự nhiên Chữa kết Hoan
quyền à Mấy ông chưa kiểm tra quyền gì
đúng không
anh cơ thả mại và điểm danh như thật ý Ô
kìa
Em chuyền kia user ID
Ừ ok tên là hơi khó hiểu tí
bộ phim Scandal
thì tại sao phải pha nhỉ
khi nó update chocolate được mà
này Tại sao phải
em phải nghỉ
Ừ nhưng phải đến là mình nhé
ở đây à
à à
Ừ nó vừa xong
sao phải đến làm gì nhỉ
Ừ mùng 4 tháng 8
v-app filter free
a secret time work
ở Tam Quốc
từ hôm trước dành cho tôi chỗ nhóm này
và hai nhóm nào đấy ngồi sửa ngoài
trường
hi how're happel bluetooth
Vì sao
đôi khi là tôi sẽ không cài cái hồi mà
tôi dậy cho sinh viên của tôi thì Thoa
tôi mới kiểm tra cố thôi còn thường mà
tôi sẽ để cho sinh viên tôi chạy thử để
mà xem là các bạn đang làm chế độ đến
đâu rồi chứ không phải tôi ngồi mò cốt
từng cái cốt như này Tôi muốn xem thì nó
sẽ vừa tốn thời gian vừa cái việc là như
nào nữa nó áo kiểu dạng là nó quá nhiều
để mình kiểm tra ai lại bạn là mày sai
rồi Bạn phải thêm chữ ép vào thì mới
truyền được Em Không Tin mới gợi ý còn
nếu mà em bỏ đi như này nó sẽ hiểu là -
1 phút thôi nó không nói truyền giá trị
vào đâu
đi quét Only
thế này Ok array to object đang làm gì
em
có một mảnh đây
Anh check Office of Death
khoa học sex sex truyền kỳ datetime West
Ham trains
di truyền kỳ vào Blue nó đi
vụ cái chân này rồi Tại sao không chỉ
với bà đấy em tí bấm vào đây Bỏ thích đi
là được mà đi đi xe bồ đi không Yêu anh
không muốn bỏ thích mày lấy rồi bởi vì
nó vỡ ý đúng mà không bỏ máy làm gì đâu
ạ
anh tặng quà trong trường hợp này mày
forex của các bạn thì đang bị này thì
mình mình có thể bỏ qua một vài cái
nhưng mà còn các bạn nó giúp cho tôi cốt
bình thường mà tôi tự nhiên tắt đi làm
gì mình tắt đi tao từ IDE biến thành em
đi tờ à
khi trở về thời tiền sử
trọng nhé kể cả về chính tả luôn
Ê mày ông có chắc tiếng anh đâu Đưa
nhiều phải sửa lỗi chính tả chứ ngon
thế
này Tam Quốc mà
a a lifetime mà chẳng có phải cái như
mình kể tôi thường hay làm để mà tôi sẽ
có một tắt đi mà tôi thường ai Cậu chọn
như này sếp to đi chuy andli này đấy thì
nó sẽ không được báo lỗi các bệnh nữa
thôi nó đấy trong
anh nói chung là đấy ở trong cẩu dự án
của tôi thôi mới xếp còn đôi nhờ cái Còn
mấy bạn thôi xếp vào túi chanle của tôi
chả làm gì cả ngoại
thấy một cái là hai đó là vi quét có thể
gọi lên ví dụ là hàm như này bằng người
quét bình thường mình sẽ dùng ghét ngay
đấy xa phía trước Nếu mình muốn cậu
cácbon con với hộ mình mình sẽ dùng làm
bếp ngay để xử lý được luôn ạ chị mãi Ôi
không gọi quét ở đây nên này thì nó sẽ
không gợi ý cho mình đâu đấy có hàng lại
rỡ chị này
thì nó sẽ có pet của mình vẫn sẽ ra được
ra được Kiểu object tao cứ thì mày uống
đỡ phải mất không phạt như thế này một
lần nữa mà đưa cho ông chị vỡ đơn giản
là gọi đến nó thì pho mát vào thôi nó cứ
kiểu như này ông sẽ chỉ cần được là nó
gọi lên pho mát ngay thôi là xong đấy
đấy là đối tượng đế luôn đấy này
a Huy thằng Hiệu đoạn này để làm gì Ok
tên của hàm truyện ngắn gọn ở cái tham
vẫn chẳng hiểu cái đoạn này ông ấy đã xử
lý cái gì nếu mà khó hiểu về mấy cái
đoạn xử lý rất lằng nhằng như thế này
thì nếu mà cốt của ông từ sự khó hiểu
như này thì tôi khuyên là
Ừ ông nên có chú thích và chú thích như
nào chú thích nên có kết quả đầu và là
gì Kết quả đầu ra là gì không biết Tôi
từng nói với ông chưa có ra sự là những
phút như này thường là viết chú thích
kiểu nó có cái Pocket để mà viết chú
thích comment nó rất là hai tham số các
thứ thứ
input Esport như thế nào Nhưng mà nếu mà
ông không thích cài tóc kịp gì cả và ông
bị lừa thì không có thể ghi kiểu đơn
giản như tôi này ra sự input là kiểu một
mảnh như này
123 chẳng ăn là sự thế nhé là sự thế
phút của ông sẽ bao giờ như thế này kiểu
234 gì đó Ừ tôi vẫn đang giả sử con nhé
con đương nhiên là cái đoạn phức tạp này
có người làm nó hơn thế rồi trả về nó
trả về à đây này Đấy sẽ bạn chất là gì
tiếng chim quốc của ông có thể đó ông ah
anh không biển cũng được nhờ ông ý nhất
bắt bộ không phải thi gạo cút để người
dùng hiểu à cái cái cái mảnh này nó sẽ
trả về trả về cái gì Ví dụ ví dụ như nãy
giờ rồi nó nhìn thực ra chỉ cần đi ngay
được rồi
à thì nó sẽ trả về cậu Muộn Màng toàn
track cậu cậu thứ đến đúng không Chị sẽ
là ô checkdate nha OK Tết Nói kiểu như
thế Happy Time tùy
Vì sao đó đi mình thể chú thích thêm đấy
update ở trong trường hợp này nó sẽ là
format nó sẽ là gì sẽ là kiểu
nó sẽ bằng kiểu oa
Em thuộc dạng mà lại có mát kiểu
anh như này đi là sửa nhà đi
anh nhìn này nó sẽ dễ hình dung nhà luôn
là là cậu người ta đỡ phải đọc cả cái
hàm của ông ngồi xem đoán về mà ông đã
làm cái gì trong này và người đang sẽ
sửa cái gì mà nó chạy được người như thế
không ạ
này mấy ông vẫn làm chung với ô nên anh
ra cốt cứ chạy được đá nhưng mà tôi góp
ý được cái gì tôi vẫn góp ý đúng không
đứng yên à Có pía mọi chuyện mấy ông
phải rút kinh nghiệm
Ê mấy ông vẫn phải tiếp tục làm nhé
Không không ngồi sửa lại cột cũ đâu
review cốt nhỉ
Ê mấy ông đều ổn hết rồi
cho tôi tôi maudon.com một vài nhóm thôi
không thể chấm chi tiết được tất cả các
nhóm và tôi
à Tôi nghĩ à thực ra cái việc mà tôi
chấm qua và nhóm như này cũng thường
xuyên như này cũng là cũng là để cho mấy
ông hình dung được qua việc là mình
mình giúp những nhiệm ở chỗ nào rồi con
để chấm chi tiết bây giờ để mà chữa chi
tiết thì chắc chắn phải có một nhóm cụ
thể nào đó nói với tôi và em muốn chữa
em thắc mắc phải tính năng khó này thì
anh chữa cho em cái thử thứ thì tôi mà
cụ thể được bây giờ coi như là nếu mà
cũng không Mấy ông không ý kiến thì cái
tôi có mặc định là mấy ông vẫn đang cốc
được nha
thì tôi sẽ những cái nhóm còn lại tôi
nghĩa sẽ chỉ
anh sẽ gọi nhà nghỉ
anh sẽ không để chấm hết rồi tất cả các
nhóm 1 lại
Anh Tạm Thời bây giờ cũng sắp bảo vệ thử
đoán rồi tôi sẽ ta chỉ mới Chị xem qua
thế thôi nhưng mà mùa và nhóm tế độ thế
thôi
Ừ thứ bảy thứ bảy nghỉ 7 mình sẽ bảo vệ
thôi lúc đấy tôi sẽ biết được vào nhóm
nào cần phải lưu ý những cái gì mà tôi
sẽ chữa cụ thể những cái nhỏ mới riêng
sau buổi hôm nay thì nếu không còn thắc
mắc Sướng nhỉ
chấm theo kiểu là ngồi xem từng chi tiết
thế nữa đâu Mấy ông phải tự sai mà tự
rút kinh nghiệm thôi
ở những cái tính năng khó thì mày ông sẽ
inbox riêng có tôi này một cái chỗ trực
tiếp livestream như này tùy
máy vì mặc định là
em đã hiểu hết mà đúng
tai nghe Bộ hôm nay mình sẽ tạm ngừng
đây nha